during real time you said that Islam is
the mother lode of bad ideas now I've
seen since I've seen you tweet at
someone you tweeted a couple weeks ago
at somebody that Judaism is a mother
lode of bad ideas well I should have
said is it the mother lode yeah well I
mean that was that was the one moment in
that exchange with with a flick where it
seems to me I misspoke I mean it was
just insanely as opposed to a you know
it's like because I obviously I've
written I've written more about
Christianity than Islam right so I
criticize religion in general I think
faith based religion is the mother lode
of bad ideas and faith based thinking
this idea that somehow you're wanting
something to be true is a good surrogate
for evidence that it is true right and
and a way in which you can embrace self
deception and deception of others as a
legitimate principle that I think is a
mother lode of bad ideas and religion
has kind of a corner on that market at
the moment but islam is an especially
dangerous variant of it within our
current political reality or I should
say Islamism as opposed to Islam in
general so when you say that you're
talking about because of the geopolitics
because of the maturation of the
religion itself right we know that
Judaism is far older Christianity's
older they've gone through different
Reformation so partly this just has to
do with timing right yeah it's not all
but unfortunately it's not only timing
but timing is enough to differentiate
them because obviously Christianity 500
years ago was Christians were burning
people alive but on street corners by
the way you've written a ton about that
oh yeah isn't your saying you're saying
to me right now no I've written more
about that yeah I wrote a whole book
just on Christianity I had done that
with Islam except this this newest book
that I wrote with the Majnu was so
either there are there are historical
differences between Islam and
Christianity and other religions and
there there are unfortunately
theological differences that make Islam
a harder doctrine to modify but it's
just as a sheer matter of history Islam
has not had
a reformation a enlightenment I mean the
head hasn't had the hasn't been
modulated by modernity in the same way
and you're talking about for the most
part people who have been intellectually
isolated to a degree that it should be
unheard of but is is still quite common
in the 21st century and unhappily they
are they're isolated from the ideas and
ways of thinking that to give us science
and give us a commitment to human rights
and give us a commitment to pluralism
and democracy but they're not isolated
from the destructive enabling technology
that we've produced so you have people
who are legitimate engineers right and
legitimate you know computer scientists
even who are jihadists right who wanted
who will use the tools of modernity
against any kind of set of modern values
that that you know we would be wise to
defend yeah all right so I think what
you said is it is not the mother lode
but it is a mother Louis within the
context of timing geopolitics and a
whole bunch of others ya know I
certainly should have said a mother lode
about it
you